- You see I got the shirt
tucked in, right?
- That don't mean nothing to me.
- You know what that means?
- No, I don't know what it means.
- I got this shirt
tucked in, right?
- What's that mean?
- That means you learned how
to put your shirt in your pants.
- Listen, when you go on a job
don't you go
with your shirt tucked in?
Cuz you mean business, right?
Hello.
I am Chad Johnson.
I am here with my good friend
and Hall of Fame
receiver Terrell Owens
and up-and-coming
draft prospect
one of the best receivers
in the nation, Riley Ridley.
- Riley Ridley stepping up!
- Touchdown, Riley Ridley.
- Touchdown, Georgia!
- What do you feel like your
best asset is as a receiver?
- Right now, I'm physical.
- OK.
- I'm physical, more physical
than any receiver
going into the draft.
I'm more physical than any DB.
- So that's something that
you don't have to work on.
So now, you gotta worry about—
work on the finesse part of the game.
- So you got T: muscle.
- Right.
- Physical.
- Physical, get through you,
and then you have my skill set
where it's completely opposite.
"Don't touch me."
How I like to do it—like,
I like to get jiggy at the line.
Man, let's ride with it.
Oh, 'scuse me.
And I need all this space.
- My coach said—
he said this to me
because he knew
I liked basketball.
- Right.
- And this is what clicked for me.
He said you have to treat
the defensive back
like you're playin' one-on-one.
If you playin' one-on-one
and you tryin' to get by me
what are you gonna do?
- I'm gonna make some moves.
- You gotta make me move.
- Right.
- Same thing with every route,
pretty much
cuz I'm tryin'
to score a bucket.
- That's what I'm tryin' to get at.
I'm here.
I'm gonna give you two steps
and then I'm gettin'
right into this.
- OK, show me.
- So I'm here, and I'm gone.
- OK.
Initially when you came off
the ball, boom-boom
you kinda
got wide a little bit.
Try to stay a little—
Try to engage them a little bit
more, you know what I mean?
- Absolutely, mhmm.
- So I like what you did.
Boom-boom-boom, here,
then kinda get into him.
Invite him.
And when you here, you wanna
show that acceleration
like you about to go deep.
- Deep.
- Then you stop.
My problem was, when I used
to get it going in my breaks
I used to—yeah, I used to have
these flappers right here.
Then my coach told me
I had to be a drummer boy,
you know what I mean?
Be a drummer boy.
Then when I did, when I did it here
transition, it's in
and out of my breaks quick.
- Right.
- We're trying to get you
to become a salesman
before you actually a salesman.
I do a dig route based off
a, off a comeback stance.
I call it send the dude
to the Gatorade.
I'm gonna send him
So, just say—
come here, come in here.
Just say the ball is in there.
- Right.
- The ball is in there.
And I got a dig route.
So this is what I'm gonna do.
Boom, boom,
I'm gonna get him right here.
Aha.
I—oooh.
I'mma send him
to the Gatorade.
- No doubt.
- All this right here is open.
Cuz as soon as you nod
that way, he gone.
- And very seldom on deep balls
do you just blow by a dude.
That ain't happenin'.
- Yeah.
- That ain't happenin'
unless you just beat
somebody off the line.
You just gas him.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, you got to be
goddamn Tyreek Hill or some—
That's a different ballgame.
- Randy is one of those guys.
- Randy.
- There's a few guys.
- Yeah, Randy, you see
the mailbox like—
- When he throw that hand up—
- It's really over.
- Not, not everybody is like that.
He's freakish.
Just freakishly fast,
you know what I mean
to the point that he start
coming off the line
and he already
sticking his hands up.
Right,
he's sticking his hands up.
- DB five yards away,
he gonna throw his hand up.
It's a bunch of receivers
in the NFL.
There's 32 teams.
There's a No. 1
on every team.
- Right.
- What's the difference in each
No. 1
and the rest of the receivers
on the team?
It's something about that dude
that makes him special.
It's something about Odell
that makes him different
than the rest of the Giants receivers.
- Right.
There's something about AB
that makes him special.
Something about Julio.
You got to go out wherever you go,
and when you get there
there gotta be something
about f--king Ridley
that makes him special.
- Exactly.
- That separates him
from everybody else.
- No doubt.
- Whether it's the way you work
whether it's your hands,
whether it's your feet
whether it's your routes,
whether it's you
being consistent,
gotta be something. One!
Ain't gotta be
a bunch of things.
It's one thing about Floyd
that makes him great.
There's a f--kin'
million boxers!
- Yeah.
- You not gonna hit me.
I'mma hit you whenever I want.
So as a receiver, you find
whatever that niche about you
that makes you special,
it's a wrap.
- I got a brother in the NFL,
but to be able to go
through this on your own,
you know what I'm sayin'
and have great people around you
and willing to help you,
it's amazing.
- And Calvin Ridley,
if you see this
I will lock you up, period.
- [Laughing]
- Period.
- No, you ain't finna to lock
nobody up, dawg.
Nobody.
- Check my resume.